hey what's up guys my name is Cho and
welcome to episode 111 of game
programming triple one let's go a lot of
episodes um it has been a while I'm
sorry about that but I've got exams
going on at University now and I'm only
making episodes when I can which is
pretty much the case all the time but
anyway let's get on let's get on with
this so we're going to talk more about
fonts today so uh and hopefully finish
up with all the font stuff today so we
got this uh thing that I I told you guys
last time um it says
gamey uh but but the idea is that um the
there's two problems here honestly
there's literally just two two problems
here first one is the fact that uh we've
got this pink background but the more
pressing one is the fact that this G
just doesn't and the Y doesn't really
look natural right because they should
be dropped a bit the actual uh I don't
I'm not like a font kind of artist so I
don't know what they're called but uh
the the lower end of G and Y should be
below the Baseline right so um how we're
going to fix that it's actually probably
more simple than you guys think think
we're going to check to see what
character we're rendering and if it's a
character which happens to have a lower
half we just simply drop it a bit so how
does that work well um the character
that we we we obviously know what
character we're going to render okay
it's called current car now the way that
I do this right now with X as well is um
I simply uh render it at um I add to the
X I kind of add an offset that's I * 16
okay it's the current character that
we're rendering along but what I'm want
to do for the Y is add an actual y
offset variable okay so this is going to
be the offset in pixels that we just
move our character and the Y um axis
okay um this is also going to work with
a cool little thing we'll add in the
future actually well in this episode
we're going to hopefully finish off
fonts but um uh you guys will see that
in a second I'll also add an uh X offset
as well cuz we might use that later okay
awesome so this y offset when is it
going to take effect and how's it going
to work well currently um we've got y of
course and then we'll obviously have a y
offset okay so what will y offset
be um well the best way to
probably uh change y offset is first of
all I'm actually going to drop y offset
and X offset into probably not X offset
but y offset at least I'm actually going
to drop into um into this uh for Loop
okay because I want it to apply to each
character individually not to all of the
characters okay um and what I'll simply
do is I'll say that if the current
character here for example um let's say
it's a
uh a y or a G right so G or Y obviously
there's a lot more like P and Q and
stuff but we'll um add those in
later then what's going to happen is I'm
simply going to drop the Y offset by
probably about let's
see um I probably set it to be about 16
I really don't know we're going to play
around with this so let's save that and
let's let's run it and see what happens
okay so 16 was way too much 16 was
actually the size of our things but you
can see that it's kind of working
right um all I'll do is I'll probably
change it to be more like
four that seems probably about perfect
actually maybe
three how's
three uh three and a half would be good
we can't do that so I'll probably just
round off and go with four okay
awesome so that's problem one fixed okay
let's try and um go back to gamey here
and let's put up every single character
we'll keep an a there for reference um
but we'll put every single character
that has that little thing going on so
PJ
Q what else is there is that it
pjq um oh things like
commas full stop um that'll probably be
it for now so if we if we run this and
render it we can say that commas also
they're above and they kind of look
weird and same with the other ones so
what we'll do is we'll um we might have
to treade commas in uh like full stops
periods whatever
separately um hopefully not though um so
if current car
equals let's
say um so what was a
q
or
um comma we'll do them later p is also
the other one that I was thinking of
P um I think oh J should probably do
this in alphabetical order but well um
J or comma
or uh full stop so it's quite a um
long uh if sa you I want to divide this
up into two so let's save this though
go back okay
um yeah so stuff like see the full
Stop's way too low right it's not
supposed to be that low um so we'll have
to tweak that in fact I don't think the
full stop actually needs a change the
comma does but I don't think the full
stop does so I'm actually going to
remove the full stop or if you're from
America it's called period um but we get
rid of
that okay oh wait did I get rid of the
comma as well did not mean to do that
okay so we'll get rid of the full stop
all right fantastic so um this is I
think that's pretty much perfect it's a
bit hard to see because of the pink uh
background so let's remove that okay um
again the way that we remove that is
very very simple we simply go
into uh render Sprite okay um I'll
probably uh add a add an alpha kind of
thing you know if we want to use alpha
or not um
I'll actually set it to be an INT that
won't be nice um one of the things that
we've done and you guys might have let
me not full screen that cuz I can't but
um one of the things that we've done and
you guys probably noticed this is
because we we've obviously dealt with
that before we always had this if color
equals that um then we've got an alpha
alpha channel so this is all hardcoded
in we never set it to a variable okay
and that's just because this is the way
this engine is going to work um if you
did want want to be really cool you'd uh
probably just do something like Alpha
color okay and you would make a private
final uh int here called Alpha whoops
called Alpha color and set it equal to
that okay um and we might just do that
okay just so it makes sense what we're
doing as well when you're actually
reading the code so we'll set um
everywhere we have that which is over
here and here we'll just set it equal to
Alpha color in here um and that's
probably
it yep okay awesome
so um for our render Sprite Which is the
one that we're doing we'll just check to
see if um color doesn't equal Alpha
color then we'll render okay um and we
obviously need to actually grab color I
call it color just because it's the
color of the actual pixel that we're
rendering at the moment right um you
could call it pixel but you know I've
already got an array called pixels and
you might get confused so I call it
color um but what that represents of
course in case you guys don't know is
the actual color of the pixel we're
about to render so we check that color
and we say if that color is a color that
we should render just don't render that
particular pixel and thus of course it
won't change the existing pixel um and
you'll see the stuff behind it okay so
to speak even though there isn't
actually anything behind it it's just
not going to change the color of the
pixel from like brown or whatever the
floor color is that being said um we
should get rid of that stuff now good
now one thing that's kind of wrong here
as well is the purple um now there's two
ways we could deal with it probably the
preferable way um to maintain Integrity
is to actually get rid of it in the file
so make it only be a pink background um
alternatively you could just simply
check for that color as well okay which
is 7f 07f which is exactly half um well
was it half uh half red and half blue
right simple as that um that being said
uh I added one extra zero that being
said um we probably will leave that just
here just for fun um so if we launch
that you'll see that it
will damn it okay
um change that to an and um we'll see
that we'll actually get rid of that and
it'll work nicely but but um yeah again
it's it's up to you what you want to do
okay um it'd probably be better to
remove it from the file because
otherwise you'd have to add another
variable this has Alpha color too okay
or you'd have to play around with you
can't really all them together so that
wouldn't work either okay anyway that
being said um we're done here so let's
go ahead and actually write a proper
sentence to see if this works so hey
guys my name is the
chero so we've got plenty of Y we've got
Comm as we've got a full stop at the end
okay all right so apart from the fact
that it went off the screen that looks
pretty good okay there's some alignment
issues you can see like the Y is
probably a bit too low or the G is like
that y looks fine so you again you can
play around with this by yourselves I
think that's pretty good um one thing I
do want to add there's two things that I
want to add uh that we have left to do
in this episode okay um and that is uh
what I talked about with the X offset
okay so I'm want to actually make
another way that you guys can render
text okay there's one where you just put
in the text in the screen that that is
the bare minimum way that you do it okay
um oh in fact we aren't even specifying
a position yet okay uh so that that
shouldn't be possible at all okay so in
X and in y okay which will replace these
two that that'll be the base kind of way
okay and this won't have an X offset now
um well it will because we'll use the
different method you guys will see in a
minute but um let's grab this right uh
and we'll add another parameter here uh
called spacing okay and the spacing will
just be how far apart the characters
actually are so let's delete that um the
spacing okay will be applied uh right
now to the X um offset all right and
then what we'll have to do is the
spacing of course is determined by this
so the spacing should be 16 by default
but we don't want it to be 16 um as in
we don't want to have to specify a
spacing of 16 because a spacing of zero
should be the default which is 16 so
what we'll do is we'll simply say 16
plus uh spacing in fact we don't even
need the xof set variable okay 16 plus
spacing all right and that will enable
us to actually control the exact um
spacing that being said we don't need to
duplicate this method because that would
be quite bad because if we change
something here we'll have to change it
here as well so what I'll do is I'll get
rid of that completely and just simply
call the render function with the
spacing parameter zero okay and that's
it everything else will'll take the
parameters from this method okay
fantastic so let's go back to game we
now have to specify something like 50/50
that will work but let's actually
specify a spacing of about -4 to bring
the characters closer
together and make them friends um there
we go so that's closer together you can
see some that might be a bit too much so
we might put it to like negative3 or
something but the idea is we now have
this uh ability to kind of play around
with how far apart um the characters
actually are so we could set this to be
something
like 10 and they would be as you can see
very far apart so you can play around
with that um and that's probably nice
now one thing that I really wanted to do
okay is occasionally sometimes we want
the ability to draw a kind of a big line
of text okay so we we basically want to
maybe write a paragraph and display it
on the screen right now the only way we
can do that is for example if I want to
separate these two maybe at the at the
point where says my name because then it
Trails off the screen I don't want that
so we'll say that after this I want this
to be on a new line so what I'll have to
do right now is simply copy and paste
this right and then put this in
here um let's get rid of all this
spacing uh and then drop this down well
we know that it's 16 so I'll drop it
down probably about well I guess that
much right so 66 so if iender this now
we'll get two lines okay um that might
be not enough as well so I might drop it
down let's just say 20 okay there we go
so that's kind of the the deal right now
um that doesn't really look good in code
okay it's like hey guys my name is the
CH like it's just it's really not nice
to write that so what we want to do is
we want to kind of be able to keep it in
the same render call um but somehow make
it Dr do a new line maybe when we hit a
new line character okay so right now if
I launch this it's just not going to do
anything because it's going to not find
that character but what I want the new
line character to actually do is to drop
it to a new line right so let's make it
do that okay if the current
character were to equal a new
line which is of course a back
sln um we want to just simply
add 16 or set the Y offset to be 16 or
well actually 20 so the it looks a bit
nicer okay um if you guys Implement uh
I'm not going to do this personally but
if you guys do Implement stuff like um
the size of of fonts so you might want
to specify font size like 16 or 20 and
it'll actually render it at that
particular scale um you'll of course
have to tweak this so it makes sense
with the scale um I'm not going to do
that just because it's not needed yet it
will be in the future and I'll probably
cover that but I'm I again this series
is really big there's so many things
there is to cover so I can't go and
complete everything this isn't a uh a
series on how to make a um a text
rendering engine okay but the idea is
well I really wanted to add the new line
character because it just makes so much
sense so it will drop the offset um by
20 now that's not good enough okay
that's not good enough because and I'll
show you why because right now what we
have here is hey guys my name is and
then the new line my name and then is a
Cho okay what will happen here it'll
partially work I guess actually won't
work at all um let's get rid of the
other instance I had so let's go back to
render for a second um y offset are we
rendering based on that we are indeed y
+ y
offset um if the current character
equals a new line let's just make sure
we didn't scroll anything up here no
that looks good let's uh go back here
and see what happens so we don't
actually
get this is going to be impossible to
say um let's do something like
this
hey bro okay so what's going to happen
here there we go no new line why does
that happen let's go back into render
and find out whoops that is the wrong
render method font. render so it doesn't
take a genius to find out that the
problem is because it's only going to
apply to this current character okay so
that's why this y offset we kind of need
to take out sometimes um I don't want to
do it that way because we do use y
offset for here and it only wants to
apply to one character so what I'll do
is I'll make another kind of Y offset
which I will call line okay I'll set
that equal to zero okay now the line is
a very special kind of thing okay
because what we're going to do is we're
going to actually add line and then
times the I guess padding sort of or the
vertical amount so 20 as I said so
instead of setting the Y offset to 20
which in your head might be the obvious
thing to do that's not really going to
work cuz it's only going to apply for
this character it's it's not going to
render that character at all cuz it
doesn't know what it is um it's going to
be negative 1 right so it'll go back
here and it will just simply say y off
it back to zero and R of the rest as it
was okay that's still not good enough
though and I'll show you why but we'll
set line equal to one or
actually we'll just go line Plus+ okay
so that's the idea let's render this now
okay that kind of worked it it did drop
it down a line definitely but
um we've got this this thing where it's
kind of not working right it's it's
supposed to put the Bro back but it's
not so one one more thing I want to
explore is if what if we add two new
lines that will work yeah it will drop a
new line okay that's why I added the
line Plus+ thing which was in here okay
fantastic so what do we need to do well
turns out that putting um this back
isn't isn't good enough we can't just
simply drop the line and expect it to
work what we actually have to do is grab
the x value of the b in this case and
put it back to the start okay that's why
we need an X offset variable that I kind
of hinted at before so we'll set that
equal to zero okay X offset right will
be
um X offset every time we render a
character okay X offset will uh
basically We'll add this to X offset
okay and then we'll just go plus X
offset so every time we're enter
character we're going to grab X offset
and we're going to add that much to it
okay 16 plus spacing okay um that's cool
and then we're going to so let let's
just make sure this works yeah it does
fantastic when we do hit a new line
character we want to advance the line
and we want to do one more important
thing and that is the X offset we want
to reset back to zero okay let's render
this now look at that fantastic okay
let's go back to game get rid of that
second new l
character and there you have it hey bro
okay that's really useful okay because
if I want to write a long sentence like
my name
or hey what's
up guys my name is the
CH all right if I want to do something
like that and I'll be like oh well
actually you know maybe after the like
before the up or something I want to
make a new line and then maybe again
here I can do that really easily without
having to duplicate this uh this
statement and you can see it will work
okay um good that's awesome fantastic so
we've got text rendering working really
well which is good um I was going to
leave it there but actually I've just
just decided I want one more thing okay
um this is kind of a major thing but I
want to be able to pick the color easily
okay so that being said um we know that
the base color is black that's cool but
um the problem is really with render
Sprite okay we're going to copy and
paste render Sprite we're going to call
it
render run a text
character okay um it's going to be
largely the same as you can see okay
except for one important thing we'll
actually have a
color uh so we'll just say in color
maybe over here okay this color will
actually be what we kind of put here
okay now
there's several different ways we could
do this okay um right now we we could
really kind of skip the entire process
and do it pretty easily okay we just
simply set color here okay let's try and
run that and see what happens so I'll
I'll call render text
character and get rid of this
stuff okay um so we'll need one more
parameter of course after the uh thing
here which is the color so for example
I'll just set it equal to well white
okay
um have I messed up the
order in ins Sprite in bullying in ins
Sprite oh what did I
do I forgot the uh comma thought so all
right so if we run that okay that works
yeah that's a bit of a cheap way of
doing it but it does work and if we get
rid of uh the exra alpha Channel it will
still work okay um and using that of
course we can set it to anything we want
so if I want a bit of a darker kind of
white so just like a bit of a gray I
guess um I can set it to that if I want
it to be a dark kind of red not dark red
but a fairly dark red uh medium kind of
red we can do that as well so you can
play around with this and you can um do
it that way now of course we don't want
this to be hardcoded we want it to be a
parameter so I'll set this thing to say
color and then up here in spacing and
color now if we don't specify a color it
will simply uh adop uh black for us okay
and then finally just to make it a bit
easier sometimes we want spacing but no
color so I'll change
this so here we are specifying color but
no
spacing and
then sometimes we want to specify
spacing but no
color so the color will be Black by
default Okay so we've got a few
different ways to do this um this isn't
actually going to work you might have
noticed that because um they're both
integers and it doesn't know which one's
which so for
this
um I'm going to say we have to choose
okay and I'll probably
say spacing is pretty important but I'm
going to say color he's going to win
over that okay so we got few different
methods we could just Chuck on an extra
parameter by the way and make the other
one work but I'm not going to bother
with that okay that's font rendering to
the absolute extreme we can do anything
we want with it now this is is trailing
off we can drop it down a line we can do
we can change the color we can change
the spacing um and we can render
whatever whatever font we want okay the
only thing you can't do is scaling okay
and I'm not going to implement that
until it's very very very heavily needed
okay hope you guys enjoyed this episode
of game programming now if you want to
support me so that I make more of these
videos I do have a patreon page okay um
I have I don't really advertise this
very often but I do have one of these
you you guys can basically pledge it's
kind of like Kickstarter but you guys
pledge per video instead so you can give
like a dollar you can if you don't have
a dollar you can actually give 50 cents
um you can give as much money as you
want per video based on how much money
you give you get certain perks of course
um and uh the idea is of course every
time I put out a video patreon charges
you the amount that you pledge um in
response you get certain rewards and of
course I get that money so that I can
spend more time making these videos um
if you want to learn directly from me so
if these tutorials aren enough for you
and you guys just want to accelerate
your learning I do offer um private
tutoring okay you guys can basically
just fill out this form hit submit it'll
send me an email and I'll catch up with
you and we will discuss a time and uh
make a booking for me to teach you
privately okay thanks for watching guys
next time we're actually going to talk
about Sprite rotation been very heavily
requested one more thing I actually
wanted to um talk about is my forums
okay because it's a pretty active place
um I'm no nowhere near as active as I
would like to be that's why I've got two
awesome moderators Andy Solace and crazy
rusi thanks
for I guess those people being awesome
um and agreeing to moderate my forums
but the idea is that if you guys are
having any kind of problems with game
programming 3D game programming nwork
chat programming anything really or you
just want to find someone to collaborate
with on making games or you want to show
off your awesome game talk about
anything in the off topic area this is a
great place to do it okay particularly
if you have problems with game
programming okay um and if you guys
request features and stuff like video
request Sprite rotation this is where I
got the idea from I said I'll probably
do Sprite rotation next okay so the idea
is if you guys want me to do something
if you want to discuss um problems you
might have then the forums are
absolutely fantastic place to do that
okay and so next video we will be doing
Sprite rotation and I didn't actually
say this at 1:00 a.m. but the point is
that next next video we will do Sprite
rot
and
um and it'll be a lot of fun because a
lot of people think it's really hard
it's really not so I'll see you guys
next time which will hopefully be later
this week
[Music]
goodbye